[Music]
rich city folk live in fancy apartments
but their hair is so polluted they can't
even see stars would that be out of our
minds trade places with any of dr. Kaler
sadly sure in order to real school a
real school this is as real as it gets
kids you learn from living hack yourself
a tooth rusty back yourself flavoring
I'm gonna tell about of you change of us
just cuz we choose to different life
calling you did you lose your sense of
adventure
if there's some let's go get better our
campus our the kids are tired of moving
to a new town every time you lose a job
you know all this running around only
temporary we just need perfect location
then we can get to work on our cash
please doesn't have any running water or
electricity ignore her she was born
without Beijing my parents are squatting
in an abandoned building on the Lower
East Side do you honestly tell me that
you're happy right now yes I am what we
like other people
we got a fire burn bellies you were born
to change the world not just add to the
noise why do you think all of us ran
away from you we were drowning
big
I never had anything bad I can't let you
cling to the side your whole life just
cuz you're scared it was your job to
protect us you have a right to be angry
I know you love him you'll regret
you ready
ow
so you might be him like you I'm glad
[Music]